>>> TOPPING OUR WORLD LEAD
TODA RUSSIA HAS MOUNTED A
COORDINATEEFFORT TO TRANSFER
STOLEN UKRAINIAN LAND INTO
PUTIN'S HANDS.
PRO-RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES IN
FOREIGN OCCUPIED REGIONS CALLED
FOR A REVERENDA TO OFFICIALLY
JOIN RUSSIA.
SOME OF THOSE REFERENEDA START
ON FRIDAY.
CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH GOT
ACCESS TO AN EASTERN TOWN UNDER
CONSTANT SHELLING, AS THEY
RUSSIANS BEGIN TO RECRUIT
CONVICTED FELONS INTO THEIR
RANKING.
>> Reporter: THE MOOD HERE IS
BLACK AND OLD.
UKRAINE TOOK HEAVY LOSSES,
STRUGING TO HOLD ON, BUT THE
RUSSIAN ENEMY IS SOMETHING NEW.
THIS IS A VERY FRONT LINE WITH
RUSSIA POSITIONS LITERALLY 100
METERS AWAY FROM WHERE I'M
STANDING.
THE KREMLIN WANTS THIS CITY, SO
HERE ON ITS EDGES, IT'S SENT
RUTHLESS MERCENARIES.
THEY SEE THE FIGHTER LEADING THE
UKRAINIANS TO OPEN FIRE.
THEY SAY THE RUSSIAN MERCENARIES
PREFER TO TRY TO RUN AT THEM, SO
THE ARTILLERY CAN HIT WHERE THEY
ARE.
THE FIELD BETWEEN THEM, CHARRED,
POCK-MARKED, ALMOST EYEBALL TO
EYEBALL.
THE NEXT ATTACK IS IMMINENT.
WE CAN SEE A MORTAR UNIT, THE
DRONE OPERATOR SAYS.
THEY'RE PREPARE TO FIRING AT US.
DOWN IN THE SHELTER, THE
COMMANDER SAYS THEY HAVE
CAPTURED RUSSIAN CONVICTS WHO
WERE RECRUITED TO FIGHT.
IT'S GET SHOT OR SURRENDER, HE
SAYS.
THEY ACT PROFESSIONALLY NOT LIKE
USUAL INFANTRY UNITS.
SHELLS CONTINUE TO LAND ALL
AROUND THEM.
THE CITY IS A MESS.
RUSSIA EDGING TOWARDS IT, BUT
NOT INSIDE.
PREPARED FOR STREET-TO-STREET
FIGHTING, AND MEANWHILE, TORN TO
PIECES.
THE LOSSES ARE HEAVY, AND
EXPOSED POSITIONS AROUND THE
CITY, PARTICULARLY HERE.
RUSSIA'S INVASION IS TEARING
THROUGH THE GREEN TREASURED LAND
IT CLAIMS TO COVET.
WHY DO THEY WANT THIS SO MUCH?
THEY WERE TREATED ELSEWHERE AND
NEED A VICTORY, SO THEY THROW
FORCES HERE.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE CASUALTIES.
NOT TODAY IN OUR UNIT, BUT YOU
CAN'T AVOID DEAD OR WOUNDED.
I LOST MY CLOSE FRIEND FIVE DAYS
AFTER WE CAME HERE.
THERE ARE STILL MANY PEOPLE
HERE, BAYING A LOT OF NATALI'S
POTATOES.
WHO KNOWS WHERE THE SHOOTING IS
COMING FROM OR GOING.
DON'T BE SCARED, SHE SAID.
24 HOURS LATER, A UKRAINIAN
ARTILLERY IS HITTING POSITIONS
ON THE CITY'S EDGE, AMID REPORTS
THAT RUSSIA HAS GOT CLOSER.
MUCH FRESH SMOKE, AND IT'S
ALWAYS HARD TO KNOW WHAT MOSCOW
THOUGHT IT WAS HITTING.
WALKING HOME WITH A SQUEAKY
WHEEL AND FOOD IS MARIA, BACK TO
HER SON.
SILENCE AND TERROR IN TURN
ENVELOPING THE CITY.
JAKE, THESE FOUR REFERENDUM ARE
A BIG DEAL, MOSCOW TRYING TO GET
A GRIP OF A NARRATIVE.
THERE WERE RUMORS PUTIN MIGHT
SPEAK TODAY, AND THAT HAND
HAPPENED.
BY MONDAY OR TUESDAY, WE'RE --
IT PUTS PRESSURE ON UKRAINE TO
MAKE ADVANCES, TO TRY TO DISRUPT
THIS PROCESS THAT MOSCOW HAS PUT
IN PLAY, BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT A
WEEK AHEAD N